- [Gary] Hey guys, first of all
thank you for clicking
you're about to watch
a new video or another video on YouTube
and before you do
Two one two,
nine three one,
five seven three one.
If you are getting value
out of my YouTube videos,
what I'm doing in my text community
is bonkers, it's instant,
it's access,
it's exclusive,
and just been a lot of fun
and I've just enjoyed
texting back and forth
with a lot of you.
Two one two,
nine three one,
five seven three one.
I'm sure they're editing
something, team
I know how ya do it.
Please join my texting community
and now enjoy
this YouTube video.
- I love your slime video.
It was amazing.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- And I thought it was really inspiring
because it showed
like...
You don't need to think
about what other people think of you
or if somebody says that "You're dumb."
You say... "Okay!"
- [Gary] Okay.
(applause)
- [Gary] Come up here!
Come up here,
come up here.
Come up here.
You're the smartest girl here.
Gimme a hug.
Thank you.
- [Woman In Crowd] Yeah!
- If she knows?!
What's your fucking problem?!
♪ You don't gotta do it like me ♪
♪ Please don't be stupid like me, me ♪
♪ Ay yeah ♪
♪ Took my acid dropped out ♪
♪ Skipped class to rock out ♪
♪ Stacked the bread then I'm out ♪
♪ Bitch I got the rock now ♪
♪ Last shot up on the clock ♪
♪ No more time to count down ayy ♪
♪ Cheddar's never better ♪
♪ Fuck the money ♪
♪ I just do it ♪
♪ So my mental can get better ♪
♪ Like a veteran ♪
♪ Tryna be a better man ♪
- Just hanging out by a big fucking tree
You coulda ended up being a bus,
a tree.
It's nice out here, west coast life.
That sunshine shit, that we don't have in
New York that often.
Not in October.
Good day, 'bout to give this talk
real estate convention.
We'll see, we'll see what fire comes out.
Flew from Atlanta,
where we gave a real
banger yesterday Drock.
Who the fuck are you scared of losing to?
What's gonna happen?
Your mom is gonna call you
and be like,
"You're a fucking loser,
"I told you,
"you shoulda been a nurse."
Who gives a sh--
Say, "Fuck you Mom."
And just working on shit,
working on Empathy, Empathy Red.
Gonna be a little pop up here.
YouTube, you guys
you guys get off easy.
I don't go hard right
hooking in YouTube land.
Empathy Wines.
If you've been watching a hundred episodes
of this for free,
and you haven't supported Empathy Wines
and you buy wine somewhere else.
If you buy--
This is why I always get mad!
If you buy wine at Ralph's or BevMo!
Like empathywines.com
the Red just came out.
It's fucking fire.
$60, $70 wine in my opinion
for 20 bucks check it out.
We're baking up a 24-hour
Q&A session.
- Wow.
- That's going to be fun.
- 24 hours?
- 24 hours.
- Are you doing a podcast or...
- We're probably gonna do it as
a close--
we wanna, we have to probably take
a very high risk
on renting something out ourselves.
So I'll probably have to like
not give people excuse
to not buy a ticket.
So I'm probably gonna
I'm probably not gonna livestream it.
I'll probably put it out
a month or two after the event
just to ya know for the person that's like
debating, "Do I wanna fly in for this?"
- Or "Ahh fuck it I'll just."
- Free Red Bulls
- Yeah exactly I'll just lay 'em
but I'm gonna do it.
I'm really excited about it.
- [Man Offscreen] Do you
emphasize that to your listeners?
- What's that?
- That LinkedIn is the better
- Oh I've been pounding it for years.
- That's what I'm saying
- No worries, no worries yeah
The answer is yes
- This is good right here
right?
- Yeah no worries.
The answer is yes.
- The youngest guy in
the group by the way.
- And what's crazy about it is
as you can imagine--
- But that's smart
because I got friends that are thinking
Facebook's the platform
and I've been telling 'em
LinkedIn but they're not
- And listen Facebook's
great too
but, but it's all about--
- [Man Offscreen] But
LinkedIn's built for business.
- Yes but it's but for many many years
even the last book I wrote,
which only came out a couple years ago
I didn't even talk about LinkedIn
because it wasn't acting
the way it's acting now.
Which is my biggest thesis is,
What's the under priced attention?
Ya know what's ironic
I'm actually in the real estate business
but it's about attention.
Ya know it's just arbitrage.
And what's crazy about LinkedIn
is unlike me being right about Twitter
or Facebook
or Instagram
or Snap, or YouTube
through the years.
LinkedIn's the first one
that actually had been around
for a long time
and then became a place to do it.
- Yeah.
- Cause obviously originally
LinkedIn was a tool for recruitment
and resumes and then
five years ago became a content play
and then 24 months ago,
it just kind of triggered
where what's interesting about LinkedIn is
it's also a place now for people
that sell bikinis and jam and wine.
You could do and
You could do what you do
- Business
- But ya know what's funny?
Or entertainment.
Like there's viral content
on the stuff that you would see on
- [Man Offscreen] On Facebook.
- Yeah a hundred percent,
- Yes for sure.
- It's really
it just it took a turn
and that's what I basically do every day.
What's happening?
Where's the attention?
When or if does TikTok go from being
teenagers to 20-year-olds,
to 30-year-olds,
to 40-year-olds.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Ya know?
- It makes sense.
The nice thing about our industry too
is the construction industry
is always kind of lagged
on the technology.
So you talk about under priced attention,
it's like they're just now slowly
ramping up on LinkedIn right?
- I--
- And we've been hitting it now
for like six eight years.
- I think the thing that
you should really hit
is start your own podcast.
- Yea
- Completely geared to construct--
to the people you're trying to get to
but not from the perspective of being
an equipment provider,
just being a macro provider
of good information for them.
- Yeah.
- Being a media company
that happens to sell equipment.
- Now it makes sense.
- So what do you think of
LinkedIn Live? I've seen you
play with that a little bit.
- I, I like it
now because most people
don't have access to it.
And so when I go live I get
disproportionate awareness
- Yeah.
- Right? So...
Live products are great.
Live's hard for most people.
Live takes a different skillset.
- Right.
- Ya know?
So I love it.
But that's because I only wanna do this,
I just wanna
All I wanna actually do is Q&A
and respond and bring value ya know?
- Got a text
- Super quick about the
podcast and that equipment,
what to look out for, what to ask for?
- So the thing with, or you mean
the content or in actually
building a podcast?
- Because what you said
about creating a podcast
to explain what we do
- The big, the big, yeah so--
- Because a lot of our
customers listen to podcasts
on the way, cause there's a big commute
- I'm aware, this is why I brought it up.
I think the thing to do is
make pretend you actually are
not in the business
- That we know--
- you're in.
- Right.
That the six of you got together and said,
"We're gonna start the CNN,
"The Wall Street Journal,
"The Sports Illustrated of
the construction business.
- Look out for
- "All we're doing is bringing on guests
"we're gonna try to get Gary V!
"and interview him of like
"what a construction company should do
"to do marketing."
Like you basically take yourself
out of the equation,
take all your selfish parts out.
And you just build a podcast
that actually brings value
thus they all listen,
and they're gonna figure
out that it's you guys.
Like it's not
- Yeah.
- super complicated.
There's a lot of things I do where,
there was years that I would go by
where I didn't even
there was people that were watching me
everyday for three years
in marketing convent
didn't realize I owned a
company called VaynerMedia.
- Yeah
- Like...
- I was--
- Now! Now!
People now!
People are like,
"But what does he,"
like when they wanna harass me,
"But what does he really do?"
Like that's how little
I bring up the fact that
I run a thousand person
advertising agency ya know?
They'll figure it out.
I mean you could do it
right at the top.
Ya know brought to you by H&E ya know
equipment services and then you go
right into it.
On today's show we're gonna talk about
the tariffs coming outta China.
- [Man Offscreen] Steel tariffs
that's a big thing, we have property taxes
and we have steel tariffs.
That affects the price of our equipment,
the property tax affects--
- It's all about bringing value
to the people that you actually want
to pay attention to you
and then having the serendipity of
karma and awareness
lead to business development.
- Right, yeah.
- [Woman In Distance] Gary!
- Yo!
What's good?!
- I love you!
- I love you back!
- [Host] Now I am honored to introduce
Mister Gary V!
(Crowd cheers)
- What's good?!
What's good?!
Thank you,
thank you,
thank you, thank you,
thank you, thank you.
We're wasting time, we're wasting time!
We're wasting time, all right see ya.
My currency is being historically correct,
not a short-term check.
This is about attention arbitrage.
The thing that is historically
always created the most amount of success
in wealth, period.
And the amount of people sitting here
and lally-gagging on social media
cause they think it's a side thing
is just unacceptable.
Because if you bought a ticket to this,
you're trying to win,
that's what you're telling me.
If you bought a ticket to this,
I assume you're trying to win.
(crowd cheers)
I'm giving you, and for the lot of people
raised their hands and listen,
I watch my fans, my consumers,
my community, I watch them
leave all sorts of love for me
on the posts I put out
and then I go look at them.
Cause I'm curious
they're not living what I'm telling 'em.
I'm telling 'em to post
30, 40, 50 times a day.
They reply with a goat emoji
and everyone's feeling
good about themselves.
(crowd laughs)
I've been pushing with all my heart
for the last five years especially
to get people in this audience
and around the world to post.
I give 'em the keys every
single day for free.
My cost is double zero.
Goose egg.
Zero dollars, zeroes.
I don't want nothing,
I want nothing from you, zero.
I just want you to do it
and send me an e-mail
and tell me you did it.
And yet you don't,
and yet you don't,
and yet you don't.
And that has what has led me
to realizing, "Wow this
is a self-esteem game."
"Wow this is a judgment game."
"Wow this is people buying dumb shit,
"to impress people they don't even like,
"cause Keeping up with the Joneses,
"is the American disease."
- [Crowd Member] Hey I'm thinkin about--
- Please text me, I'll reply
- [Crowd] Gary!
- [Woman In Crowd] Now for a good picture!
- [Man In Brown Suit] Thank you for that.
- Try to go? Okay.
Thank you
- Thank you
- Thank you.
- Oh my gosh.
Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
- Good job Gary!
- Thank you brother.
Thank you for all your help.
Thank you, thank you,
thank you.
- Thank you man, awesome.
- Thanks everybody.
I wish you guys a nice weekend.
Thank you.
- [Gary] Awesome, good to see you.
- Hi, Hi Gary!
- You were amazing!
Great to meet you Mom.
- Gary Hey,
Good to meet fin-- again
I been pestering you
ever since you launched
your wine.
- Oh, hold on...
The star of my show tell 'em who you are.
- I'm Katherine Tinkersly
and I said,
that if somebody says that "I'm dumb?"
Whatever, okay.
- Tell 'em.
- I don't care!
- We don't care
- If someone calls me dumb
- about your hate!
We don't care!
- I have a song
and I have a dance I made up
called the sloth
it goes like this.
And one time at school somebody told me
that the dance was dumb
and I'm like,
"I don't care if it's dumb,
"I like it!"
- We don't care!
We can't hear you!
- Yeah I love the dance
- I love the sloth!
I'm all about the sloth!
- I don't care--
- Show me some sloth!
- I don't care if
somebody doesn't like it.
- Fuckin' sloth!
- Right to the back, go right
- Thank you guys.
I can go in here right?
Awesome, bye guys.
- Take care.
- [Women Off Screen] Love you
- Love you back.
- Damn, it's loaded up up there.
Is the guy comin?
That's good.
- Thank you Gary.
- I can.
Thank you bro.
- Can you please sign my sweater?
- Yes.
- Oh my God!
- Can I ask you a question while you're
taking pictures with them?
- Yes.
- So you know how there's
this stuff going on
like the end of the world
and the kind of like
global warming and stuff
- Yup.
- And there's two things
kind of on my mind
right now
- Okay.
- One thing like you say
you gotta keep pushing,
enjoy your life,
y'know you could live
up to a hundred years
it's totally possible
- Right.
- But then the second question is
the global warming
- You get to decide!
- the end of the world
- You get to decide.
- How do you live? Like when--
- I live easily.
Like global warming could be happening,
you get hit by a fuckin' tree tomorrow.
- That's true!
You either live on offense
or you live defense bro.
All right fellas.
- Thank you so much.
- Bye guys! Love you!
Thank you so much!
Have a good weekend!
♪ It's written in the sky like that ♪
♪ Why you high like that ♪
♪ It's written in the stars like that ♪
♪ Catchin' scars like that ♪
♪ Your heart ♪
♪ So bold, so cold, so thrown ♪
♪ You fight right back ♪
♪ It doesn't have to be so cold ♪
♪ And you don't have to feel alone ♪
♪ Lemme rock a little bit ♪
♪ Lemme rap a little bit ♪
♪ Lemme take a sec to talk
about my past a little bit ♪
♪ Lemme cry a little bit ♪
♪ And type a little bit ♪
♪ Send you back to times ♪